prendi alla mano ti serve la mano ti
serve la mano
[Musica]
quella tutti mio amico seppie merito né
dell'ultimo si spera l'ultimo per l'amor
di dio episodio di ireland ed anche
detto benedetto è che il nome che però
mi fa cagare
quindi non lo uso mai siamo arrivati
ragazzuoli l'ultimo episodio in teoria
anche altro a livelli ragazzi per
concludere tutto cosa assurdi sì ma
quindi iniziamo perché allora non so se
riuscirò a finire in quest'episodio però
spero e prego di sì un buon punto di
partenza ragazzi che non mi ricordo di
essere arrivato a questo livello quindi
che ricordiate ragazzi ma sto livello
avevo già fatto
porca eva probabilmente no salivo cosa
fa
stai calmo stai calmo che james e già è
difficile sto gioco non ci si mette pure
due ragazzi mi ricordo o dio
nola con san valentino paolo mi ricorda
neanche più a che pisodio siamo arrivati
ragazzi di rand ed solo che per ora
praticamente cristo nato per arrivare
fin qua stato impossibile se dio vuole
ragazzi che finisco questo gioco per
l'amor di dio non mi consigliate più
niente la farò mai io sono convinto di
sa cosa perfetto porca eva ladra
incastrata nel divano è impossibile cioè
quello di che è va beh oddio sono i cori
oscar stava scherzando stai calmo però
c'è praticamente ragazzi l'altro livello
di randello dovevo aspettare che la
piscina si svuotasse invece questo è il
contrario devo fare prima che si riempie
c'è un macello non solo un altro lato
c'è solo una gamba devo fare il miracolo
divino
si può rifare un check point prima di
passare la vita giusto livello no ve lo
chiedo a voi fate come cazzo voler
niente non c'è verso dai dai dai
tirano porca eva bravissimo che ansia
mezz'ora per tirare la testa che cazzo
aspetti lo scontrino
già è difficile 11 mettere pure tuo zio
aveva detto ho detto io per carità di
dio
sono vivo dai dai cosa sta cosa cosa
cazzo fai la mamma ha detto di fare il
cretino oggi dopo c'hai nel cervello ci
prova vai c'ero quasi riuscito
fatevi provare l'ultima volta ragazzi
poi non proprio perché non è possibile
sono ok fate vi aspettate
ok si si io mio non ci credo non è
possibile veramente veramente veramente
non ci può non è possibile cioè non è
mai successo nella vita di fare un
livello così in fretta
noi cazzo vado c'è qualcuno che apre il
deretano e mi sparo lì non lo di melo
dove odio se tu che cazzo sono ma no
sono uscito dalla ma ma non ci credo ho
pagato tutto veramente ragazzi ho pagato
già o che ho passato tutto quanto non è
possibile ho fatto di peggio con andava
a scuola sono arrivato a scuola per non
prendere il pullman anche scavalcando le
macchine quindi va bene questo bello
completato ragazzi se ne faccio altri
due così no questo è l'ultimo credo che
sia un box e credetemi
potrei cristo nar e parecchio che final
run run dead non ci credo mai siamo
arrivati alla fine ci ho messo una vita
per arrivare qua una vita e mezza
allora questo è il tipo che mi ha
imprigionato qua dentro in poche parole
quello che ha creato stop tutto sto
reality perché per chi non avesse
seguito all'inizio st robben reality
tipo grande fratello un po meno
ignorante la roba un po più seria hans a
zio e magnate meno prima cosa seconda
cosa si bruttona versus a perché mi
chiama si fa anche il caso che deve fare
il versus verso sedia ma vuoi vedere chi
vince bastardo verrei a prostra crede di
poter vincere partiamo serie ed hai
voglia di fare il cazzone non di melo
beh non ha voglia di fare il cazzone
regala ben 40 un paio di minuti da
canzone che gli concedo anche per poi
basta il serio ha detto ragazzi mi
sembra credo che sia un unione di tutti
oddio quanto sei inquietante quando
corri così bene ciò la precisione
nell'anima io ragazzo dicendo credo che
sia l'unione di tutti gli ostacoli
finora utilizzati credo non lo so è per
carità ma è lì col passar do lo vedete
io devo raggiungere il tipo bello lui
non ce li agli ostacoli bravo sì vabbè
ma quello ha pagato gioco perché fin
tanto io l'ho schivati tutti senza
guardare si browser
30 qua è morto è morto e non è
uno zombie lui e quindi non può
resuscitare come fa ho capito che una
gara tra noi due ma è morto
minchia io e la mira sono due cose
completamente uscisse dalla divina
creazione io ei capelli ordinati queste
due ragazze
hai voglia dichiarare ciò la precisione
nella così sono il postino salve avete
voglia posso entrare grazie dove quello
stronzo di prima ed a giugno c'è beh ho
trovato ben cazzo cedendo ben non ci
credo ho trovato non è finto sicurissimo
non è finto premi e per celebrare tutte
le brezze ok
oddio no ha già è vero che io sono uno
zombie ma no se muori ma non è vero
mano a fermo no non è possibile non può
finire così
no cazzo è vero che lui è uno zombie mi
ero dimenticato sta cosa una roba che se
l'e freight ma sta mangiando
cioè io ho passato tutto il gioco
cercando di trovare sto bambino porca
eva alla fine l'ho trovato ma me lo sono
mangiato alla fine era meglio sono fini
io sto gioco ma non l'ho finito non può
essere così scarso boss no non è vero ma
mi chiama erano amici bene
dove gli ammazzarmi
ma che brutto ma ma navigano
tornano ma non dormire o mac è vasta e
di merda tutta l'anima fatto una pena
sto cristiano e tutti i livelli si va
beh un po meno rude magari questo
ma ho veramente vinto ma mica è durato
cinque minuti 5 mi vuoi dire che il boss
finale dal tuner dozo di tutti quanti ho
finito il gioco non è possibile è
inutile che piange a ma che
bossi merdoso è questo schifo qui il 15
ci ho messo qualcosa come sei anni e
mezzo per far ma non avete idea e poi mi
fate un boss finale che dura una merda
ragazzi faccio un paio di livelli bonus
perché durato un cazzo episodi me non ci
posso mai credere finale più deludente
della storia ma neanche titanic finiva
così di merda pollice in su ragazzi se
volete tirare degli schiaffoni anche voi
a chi ha creato il finale visto gioco
solo il finale per carità perché il
gioco era figo in sé per sé il finale è
bello bella la tranvata e ho appena dato
che qualcuno qualcuno di voi non mi
ricordo chi me l'aveva detto che il
finale sarebbe stato un po una merda ma
non pensavo così di merda ma devi
crepare anche peggio se l'avessi saputo
mica fin dall'inizio non sarebbe
arrivato alla fine avrei interrotto
prima il gameplay se l'avessi saputo
prima vaio di testa di testa bravo bravo
frate bravo cosa fai prendisole ha
deciso di prende il sole rega è comodo
ciò era una giornata di merda potevi
migliore porca eva un'altra grazie
veramente non ho parole
io do porca eva laida ma perché
ciò che ti odio la famiglia almeno fai
un salto decente tutti me lo dovete
commentare sotto scrivendomi
l'incazzatura mondiale che ci avete no
perché non è possibile
madonna quanto sei storto da una mille
salta bravo zio bravo oddio anni per
arrivare quando ci posso credere
ma vedi di divenire alla fine vabbè già
era difficile dove il traguardo il
traguardo è la giunta guancia arrivo sei
volte ci arrivo credimi
va beh ci arrivò così ho deciso niente
scherzavo porca tua sorella
tozza call finale resto gioco preferito
un carcere bocca vabbè vabbè cos'è il
super bowl cos'è come sta strisciando
fate vai vai vai vai vai il rag doll il
rag doll tutto in regola perché va dai
dello zio serafin e sì alla fine che
qualcosa cazzola cosa fa cosa fai un
deficiente bravo prendi alla mano ti
serve la mano ti serve la marchei
infossi attenzione si consiglio
svegliati bravo sì sì quanto impossibile
quanto c'è mancato perché non guardo
dove vado bene di che ha imprigionato il
bambino io pensavo ho sempre pensato di
dovranno salvare ma convinto proprio
l'ultimo ragazzi l'ultimo bonus che c'è
che c'ha due checkpoint che saranno
impossibili non mi toglie le buonumore
perchè giuro che che escono dalla vita
dei ragazzi meno droghe grazie ma come
fai lo è impossibile come lo salto anzi
ho due lame 2 una su una giusta e salto
più quella su se non salto più giornale
lo spieghi cosa cazzo fai come faccio
angela faccia saltare tutti e due
non è vero due sono sono uscito che
cazzo di ballate sono qui a rega sono
qua non so se mi avete visto in teoria
che non dovrei essere fuori ai ragazzi
sarà un bug questo prove mi sto
sfruttando tutto il gioco per passare da
fuori per poter vincere il livello però
non so dove fino se riesco a vincere
così basta me ne vado dove devo andare
aveva spiegato eccolo e check point o ti
prego ti prego
oddio più filanti prego prendi il finale
è pubblico sono qui e guardate a quanto
sono dal finale non so se vi rendete
conto dai zio guarda guarda quanto siamo
ma non ci posso credere mai che non è
possibile a un mio sì ho pagato tutto ma
ho vinto io non ho parole
tante cose sono successe negli ultimi
episodi favore ragazzi ho finito tutto
tranne questo che è un livello che per
sulla carlo ci vogliono 320 scatoline si
è tradotto in italiano significa che
dovrei perdere tanta vita sociale più di
quella che per lo talmente presso
livello ed è vuoto e nero non lo
giochiamo perchè è nero razzismo sui
livelli
ricordo di aver mai giocato un finale
così de lune così tanto deludendo
bruttissimo deludente nel finale è bello
perché sorprende ma porca la eva
incastrata ancora nel divano non si può
fare tutta sta merda che mi sono fatto
non può finire così
chiudiamo la parentesi un mi piace o per
ogni mi piace è uno schiaffo e creatore
visto gioco e se ci vuole che vi sia
piaciuto finale a parte cosa state
eseguite piaciuta suo documento è un mi
piace perché al piacere di facebook e
con i video tratta descrizione si usano
i siti schede che ci vediamo al prossimo
video di belle ragazze